Traduttore: Peggy Berthier
Revisore: Maria Pia Lanfranchi
La storia di cui oggi vi voglio parlare
è una storia di sport.
Ma non dello sport fatto di vittorie,
non dello sport fatto
da chi è arrivato prima in classifica,
ma lo sport fatto e che genera positività
e cose positive per gli altri.
Uno sport che probabilmente,
poi giudicherete voi,
ci dà la forza per andare avanti,
la forza per credere.
Io sono qua in questa foto e sto correndo,
sì, perché mi piace correre.
Qua mi trovavo in Namibia
durante la prima tappa
di un viaggio lunghissimo,
un viaggio fatto di 104 Km
che poi sono diventati 106,
ne ho aggiunti due
perché 104 erano troppo pochi.
No, ne aggiunti due
perché il 6 è un numero importante
e il 6 è un numero
che ritornerà in più momenti
lungo questa storia.
E qua sono io, sono io,
alla fine di questi 106 chilometri
con tutti i concorrenti
che invece di correre,
e invece che essere preoccupati
nell'arrivare primi o arrivare ultimi,
arrivavamo tutti insieme
dopo questi 106 agognati chilometri.
Il viaggio e la difficoltà è iniziata
già subito dai primi giorni.
Siamo atterrati a Windhoek,
che è lì in alto, all'interno della mappa,
e dopo sei, sette ore di viaggio
abbastanza difficoltose
siamo arrivati nel deserto del Namib,
il deserto più vecchio del mondo.
Un deserto bellissimo,
un deserto con delle
caratteristiche particolari,
per cui l'ho scelto
per questo tipo di gara.
E qua un'altra casualità: il pettorale.
Il pettorale che mi è
stato assegnato è il numero 6;
ancora, questo 6 che torna
è un numero importante,
è un numero importante per me.
Questa è la prima tappa della gara:
la prima tappa è una tappa notturna,
una tappa di 15 km, quindi molto semplice:
si fanno 15 chilometri, tutti noi
li facciamo durante i nostri allenamenti,
però il deserto e in generale la corsa,
[è] un po' una metafora della vita:
voi iniziate a fare delle cose,
poi durante la vita
succedono gli imprevisti.
E anche nella corsa
succedono gli imprevisti:
però se vuoi portare a termine
una sfida, una gara,
sia che sia col tempo,
o sia che sia per fare qualcosa di bello,
devi comunque andare avanti
e sapere reagire.
C'è sempre, la possibilità di reagire.
E io la prima difficoltà
l'ho avuta dopo tre chilometri.
Ho freddo...
sta calando il sole...
guardate che bello...
Sono un po' emozionato...
non pensavo che fosse così bello...
grazie a tutti...
mi avete supportato...
ce la farò...
è faticosissima ma ce la faccio,
ok?
Io non mollo mai.
Esatto, non potevo mollare,
perché questa gara era associata
a un'iniziativa importante di fundraising,
un'iniziativa importante
per aiutare dei bambini,
per raccogliere fondi
per la lotta contro il neuroblastoma.
Il neuroblastoma è un tumore infantile,
che purtroppo affligge tantissimi bambini.
Io prima di questa esperienza
non ne conoscevo,
fortunatamente, l'esistenza,
però purtroppo ce ne sono tanti, tanti,
che anche in questo momento stanno male,
e quindi il mio obiettivo
era fare questi 106 km
raccogliendo fondi per dare
una speranza a questi bambini.
E quando si corre nel deserto
- è complesso, correre nel deserto,
perché c'è la sabbia,
fa caldo, molto caldo.
Nel deserto del Namib, a dicembre,
alta stagione, si corre con 61 gradi!
È vero che correre a 61 gradi
non è come correre a 61 gradi
con quel certo livello
di umidità che abbiamo noi,
però sono sempre 61 gradi, no?
Durante la tappa maratona di 42 km
che è durata, per quanto
mi riguarda, 7 ore di corsa,
ho avuto diversi problemi alle braccia,
di bruciature, escoriazioni.
Ma andava bene così.
Perché? Perché dovevamo
portare avanti la nostra gara.
Quando si corre si è soli, o quasi.
Questo era all'inizio della seconda tappa,
quella un po' più lunga, di 21 Km,
quindi nulla di drammatico
però era una tappa bella, una tappa
che ha cominciato a farmi pensare,
una tappa che ha cominciato a svelare
anche la secchezza del terreno
e il calore che c'è in un deserto.
Il deserto comincia,
e mi ha insegnato tantissimo.
Mi ha insegnato che noi,
molto spesso, per essere...
ci sentiamo anche,
durante tutte le nostre giornate,
durante tutte le nostre
attività lavorative, degli invincibili.
Ci sentiamo invincibili,
ci sentiamo potentissimi,
[il deserto merita rispetto
e insegna molte cose]
Però, purtroppo, nel deserto
ci si accorge che sei un puntino
e un puntino, magari, dove attorno a te -
io ho corso con 15-20 km
dove non c'era nulla,
e quando corri a 15-20 km
dove attorno a te non c'è nulla,
ti rendi conto quanto siamo piccoli.
E ti insegna anche
che le cose belle della vita
non sono solo il cellulare, o il vestito
all'ultima moda, assolutamente.
Molti ragazzi, per essere contenti
devono avere il cellulare all'ultima moda.
E lì ho imparato tante cose da un ragazzo
che guidava un autobus, un pulmino,
e a un certo punto, in mezzo al deserto,
una sera che andavamo a mangiare,
si è fermato, scende dal pulmino,
ci lascia in mezzo a questo deserto,
scende e va a prendere
una foglia da un cespuglio.
Ce la porta, questa foglia, e ci dice:
'annusate, annusate questa foglia'
E questa foglia era una foglia di salvia.
Lui era contento perché 'con la salvia,
non so se lo sapete, profuma,
e non so se lo sapete che con la salvia
io posso fare da mangiare.
E non so se lo sapete, ma con la salvia
io faccio anche le medicine.'
Lui era contento per la salvia.
Ora, non dobbiamo essere contenti
probabilmente solo per la salvia,
è giusto essere contenti
di tante altre cose,
ma è importante anche a volte
valutare bene quanto siamo fortunati noi.
Il deserto della Namibia
è il deserto che io ho scelto, perchè?
Perché all'interno
del deserto della Namibia
esiste la duna più alta
del mondo, più di 300 metri.
E quando sei là,
noi l'abbiamo fatta di corsa,
o quasi di corsa,
lo vedete lì sulla punta,
la bandierina, che poi
si scendeva dall'altra parte:
è come se toccasse il cielo, perché?
Perché nel deserto non esistono nuvole,
e quindi quando sei là in alto
è una cosa incredibile.
Salire sulla duna non è semplice:
io correvo poco, anzi camminavo molto.
E quando sono arrivato
sulla punta della duna
ero ormai al chilometro 100,
mancavano solo sei chilometri.
Siamo ormai al chilometro 100,
che corrisponde anche alla duna
più alta del mondo, qua in Namibia,
e ce l'ho fatta.
Adesso....
Scusate.
Mancano... gli ultimi 4 Km,
ma ne faccio altri 2.
Il progetto sta andando bene,
e sono contento.
E niente, grazie a tutti
che mi state dando forza.
E via, adesso mi butto e ciao.
- Vado?
- Vai!
- Vediamo di non cadere!
[Ciò che rende bello il deserto
è che da qualche parte nasconde un pozzo.
cit. Il piccolo Principe]
E io nel deserto ho trovato,
anche qua una citazione,
anche stamattina si parlava
de 'Il piccolo principe' e del mio pozzo
e ho trovato tante persone
che con me hanno condiviso,
se non altro le 26 persone,
perché è una gara molto...
con tanti contendenti, no?
26, erano 26... le 26 persone
che hanno corso con me,
alla fine gli ultimi due chilometri
potevano anche non farli,
perché la sfida era di 104,
[ma] hanno corso, e all'arrivo
si è realizzata una magia incredibile.
Come vedete erano tutti molto agili,
durante la partenza,
perché le gambe erano un po' rigide.
E quindi questi siamo noi,
perché l'organizzazione
che cosa aveva fatto?
A un chilometro di distanza dalla riva
aveva messo quella bandierina
per darmi la possibilità di arrivare,
finire la gara ufficiale,
poi tornare indietro,
fare l'altro chilometro,
poi ritornare indietro per arrivare a 106.
Perché? Perché il progetto
aveva l'obiettivo, appunto,
di arrivare a questi n chilometri
ed avere all'interno il numero 6,
un numero sempre importante e ricorrente.
La cosa interessante
è che noi siamo arrivati alla fine
e la raccolta fondi è terminata
e ha raggiunto il suo obiettivo
il 20 dicembre del 2016,
che se voi prendete le cifre
sono esattamente le cifre che fanno 106 km
oppure 106 x 2 = 212,
Ma io non ero così,
quindi non è che - c'è speranza
per tutti eh, non vi preoccupate:
potete correre anche voi.
Io ero così, forse anche
un po di più, avevo 40 chili in più,
non ero molto sportivo,
fumavo - a volte capita,
alla gente, di fumare,
e sicuramente facevo 100 metri
e facevo già fatica.
Non ero solo.
Scusate.
(Applausi)
Oltre ad avere una moglie,
che basta e avanza,
avevo due figli:
uno un po più grande, Riccardo,
che ormai ha 17 anni;
e l'altro, Pietro, che aveva 6 anni.
E Pietro e Riccardo,
qua durante il giorno di scuola,
quindi tre anni di differenza,
questo è il primo giorno di scuola.
Riccardo doveva andare in quarta
e Pietro in prima elementare,
quindi grandi.
Non so perché Riccardo
facesse pollice in su
e Pietro pollice giù;
evidentemente aveva già capito,
la situazione...
[Ma ... la vita ... a volte ...
ci riserva delle prove insaspettate]
Però purtroppo la vita a volte
ci riserva le cose le dure, della vita -
cioè è un po' come la corsa,
quello che vi dicevo prima:
alla fine, la fatica -
a volte devi sapere reagire.
E questo è quello che è successo.
Questa è un emorragia cerebrale.
Questa è la fotografia
di un'emorragia cerebrale.
Purtroppo, Pietro ha avuto
un'emorragia cerebrale
durante - a novembre,
durante i primi giorni di scuola,
e questa emorragia cerebrale
è stata causata
da una malformazione artero-venosa
che non conoscevamo,
durante la nascita.
E ha lottato, ha lottato duramente.
Questa è l'ultima volta
che lo vedo sorridere.
Quando sembrava che tutto andasse bene,
il 18 febbraio del 2010
purtroppo ci hanno chiamato
e ha avuto un infarto,
perché era troppo stanco.
E quindi la gara si chiama Taran 106.
Pietro - avete capito, il numero sei.
Chiaramente,
non voglio dare un'impressione brutta,
ma in questi momenti...
[il sole risorge sulle nostre vite,
anche quando non riusciamo a vederlo]
non bisogna abbattersi, ma bisogna -
(Applausi)
Ma bisogna continuare,
per dare comunque
la forza a chi è rimasto,
perché ricordatevi che i problemi
sono sempre di chi rimangono...
e a Riccardo continuare
ad andare avanti nella vita
e dare la possibilità
agli altri due che sono arrivati:
è arrivata Emma,
Emma è arrivata il 29 giugno, San Pietro,
e successivamente è arrivato Michele,
18 mesi dopo, quindi ci sono loro.
Bisogna assolutamente essere positivi
e anch'io non potevo abbattermi.
E quindi, assolutamente,
ho dovuto fare che cosa?
Riuscire a crearmi,
o migliorare, la mia vita,
a migliorare la mia forma
non solo dal punto di vista,
diciamo così, visivo,
ma soprattutto dal punto di vista fisico
per poter dare la forza alle persone.
E per essere io, più forte.
E quindi ho cominciato a correre:
la prima immagine che vedete a sinistra
è la mia prima mezza maratona
all'interno dell'arena di Milano,
e poi un'altra arena, un anno dopo,
la prima maratona
all'arena di Verona, bellissima.
E fino ad arrivare a questa gara.
Fino ad arrivare, appunto,
al deserto della Namibia,
dove, appunto, questi 106 chilometri
mi hanno portato a vincere questa medaglia
ma ad aiutare tantissimi bambini
che avevano bisogno.
E vedete lì la maglietta,
quello è il simbolo,
io ce l'ho tatuato addosso,
Ed è...
sono io e sono Pietro:
è per quello che volevo raccogliere
21.200 euro, che è 212x2,
perché io non ho corso da solo
all'interno del deserto
e continuerò a non correre da solo.
Quest'anno a novembre
andrò nel deserto dell'Oman,
e i chilometri saranno 165,
quindi anche qua ci sono
delle combinazioni di tanti 6.
165 chilometri
totalmente in autosufficienza,
quindi mi daranno solo l'acqua,
vediamo e speriamo
di arrivare fino alla fine.
Il deserto è diverso,
ma l'obiettivo è sempre il medesimo,
cioè riuscire a raccogliere i soldi
per aiutare dei bambini,
e aiutarli a farli stare meglio.
Il messaggio quindi che vi dò oggi
è un messaggio importante:
qualsiasi siano le difficoltà
che noi possiamo avere,
grandi o piccole che siano,
c'è sempre una speranza per tutti
per fare grandissime cose
e per andare avanti,
Perché la vita è un po'
come una rotella, no?
(Applausi)
[Ognuno di noi
può indossare un paio di scarpe
e cominciare a correre.
Ognuno di noi può porsi
i propri obiettivi,
piccoli o grandi che siano,
e tentare di raggiungerli.
Io ci ho provato, ed è così
che sono arrivato al deserto.]
(Applausi)
[Grazie.]
Io, oggi noi siamo qua,
ed oggi è il 17/6 del 2017.
3 volte 6, vedete voi
come volete interpretarlo.
Grazie a tutti.
(Applausi)